[Music]
this year in Europe has been dominated
by The Fallout from Russia's war in
Ukraine energy is the biggest pinch
Point prices for electricity and
especially gas rocketed governments
forced to intervene scrambling to find
alternative sources of fuel to ease the
price pressure
Germany's opened a new liquefied natural
gas terminal Spain's promising a new
pipeline the EU has capped the price of
gas but is it all enough or will the
move away from Russian energy sources
continue to hurt households and
businesses well into 2023
welcome to another DW business special
this time about the way ahead in
Europe's energy crisis and let's dig
into all of this now with the economist
and advisor to the German government
Veronica Grimm Veronica thank you very
much for joining us today um so just a
quick question before we get into all of
the weeds of this how have you
personally been affected by all this how
have you changed your energy use all
this year and in light of the economic
challenges if at all
hello and I thought you have me
um so we changed quite a lot of our
Behavior at home so um the heating is
reduced we've reduced the temperature we
try to heat as well as possible which is
very difficult in those very cold times
um and we are I'm driving much less with
the car riding bicycle going by train so
our Behavior changed quite a lot
yeah and I think that's reflected among
many households in Germany and across
Europe at the moment but I want to look
at one of the big changes that came this
week with an EU agreement to cap the
price of natural gas one expert I spoke
to thinks the cap is a bad idea let's
take a listen
it's going to work maybe not because I
mean we the objective of the commission
was to try to reduce not only the gas
price but the electricity price but
again we have to understand that we had
extreme high prices in this last year
because of the ability to Market to
mitigate the Russian disruption and this
had guaranteed security of Supply so
they the trade-off here between high
prices increased security of the price
and the cap that could reduce security
of supply
so Veronica do you agree with that so
he's talking about the trade-offs here
between security of supply and also uh
he he claimed in that interview that
this is just a market distorting move do
you agree with him after all the the
German government was initially very
resistant to ID the idea even though it
voted for it in the end
yeah I
am very skeptic
Ally you'd reduce the gas available to
Europe and um at the same time if the
price is lowered you increase demand and
then there is scarcity and you have to
ration and whenever
um the rationing has to decide who gets
the gas and not the market via prices
and it is quite likely that you um just
get a mess in certain Supply chains
because if you do it by rationing you
cannot be sure that you do not for
example interrupt uh Supply chains where
it is a very
um damaging to Value creation and so to
uh to economic
um growth um in the in the future so I
think it is a bad idea I think the
implementation is such that that in
principle you can avoid this so the
price cap is loosened if you then do not
get enough gas
um at the World Market
um and this might um this might reduce
uh the bad effects of the price cap but
in principle I'm skeptical
okay well the EU Nations that had that
voted in favor of it basically said that
drastic times cause uh call for drastic
measures but if not this what should the
EU be doing to let's say mitigate the
impact on on households and businesses
of the the massive cost of energy at the
moment
I think it is very important to get add
gas into Europe on the one hand to
procure gas worldwide and also diversify
the contracts that we have in order not
to become dependent from uh just another
um State um in the world as we have
become dependent on Russia
um and the second issue is of course
um Energy savings so we all have to save
energy and first and foremost safeguards
and there's a lot of opportunities we
see that because the price has become so
high and there were a lot of
initiatives to save energy and we have
in Germany for example we have saved 20
of gas in Industry roundabout but the um
value creation did not drop very much so
you see that there was a lot of
potential to safeguards and I think this
is the way we have to go we will not get
the prices down and two historical
levels
not nearly down to historical levels
um and for the rest of the burden you
have to um use relief payments in order
to make it bearable for households and
firms
well I mean it makes sense what you're
saying of course diversifying Supply and
Germany has tried that for example
turning to Qatar doing an an energy deal
with them to help Supply its needs but
of course the the problem is extremely
complicated I mean we've seen him in
previous wind Winters for example Asian
Nations bidding up the price of
liquefied natural gas and also as we've
seen with the whole Qatar story there's
a limited amount of big suppliers that
can supply Europe gas at the right price
so isn't the the worry here that Germany
for example will fall into the same trap
as it did with Russia relying on those
few countries that can supply enough
energy to it for example Qatar
uh yeah that's uh exactly uh the danger
and that's why we have to diversify and
I think we have to think about both we
have to think in the short run where to
get gas from and this is most likely LNG
and there are of course uh the States
from the um Mina region so Saudi Arabia
Qatar is the United Arabic Emirates
um but there are also other regions
where we can get a gas from an
particular we have to comp combine
um these procurement Endeavors with the
procurement of uh renewable energy
hydrogen and derivatives of hydrogen
many um areas many states worldwide
prepare for the export of hydrogen and
since Europe does not want to use gas
for longer than say 10 or a little bit
more years we have to combine the
procurement of gas with the procurement
of hydrogen and the good news is that
there are worldwide many more states
that have good conditions to produce
renewable hydrogen then there are states
that dispose of resource of fossil fuels
so um for the future I think if we
really go for renewable energy
um to import your renewable energy I
think we have a good chance to diversify
our value chains in the short run I
think we have to improvise
um and procure gas
um how where we get it
um and at the same time safeguards in
order to be not too dependent on gas
um in the um interim phase in this
crisis in many European member states
there have been
um measures like extending the runtime
of coal power plants extending the
runtime of nuclear power plants so there
are all kinds of measures in order to
avoid the consumption function of gas
and to reduce the necessity
to import a lot of gas to Europe and
substitute the whole
quantity that we procured from Russia
okay well um I mean you you definitely
wrapped up a lot of different things
there so let's pick that apart over the
next few questions so looking at some of
the other uh initiatives European
nations are taking Germany has just
begun final tests on a floating LNG
terminal in wilhelmsafen which will
allow for liquefied natural gas Imports
into Germany it's also struck as we
heard a deal with Qatar to supply LNG
and has come to an agreement at this
stage it's just an agreement with Spain
on the building of another pipeline to
increase energy security so how much of
a game changer is the new German LNG
terminal if we just start with that for
liquefied natural gas Imports
I think it's a it's a big big game
changer
um because
um in the past
um several economists
um and cons and institutions have
already advised that Germany should
build LNG terminals in order to increase
the possible competition at the gas
market in Europe and um this advice had
not been followed and now we are
building LNG Terminals and I think this
is the right way to become
um more independent we need energy
Imports of course also in the future but
we should try to organize our energy
Imports such that we are not dependent
on one particular country that provides
the energy but that we are importing
from many countries so that we can live
with it if one country does not supplies
so we are not exposed to such a high
risk as we have been exposed to in the
past
I think a lot of Germans will be
listening to this though I'm feeling a
bit frustrated that we've spoken about
this switch to renewable energy for a
long time the so-called energy vendor
for what is it it could be 20 years now
and so um it seems that Germany's
transition to Renewables has just been
far too slow why is that because that
would have really helped us out in this
situation as well as fulfilling the the
climate targets that the gov the German
government has committed itself to over
many years
yeah I think we have to be too slow
that's true
um but at the same time uh some good
news is
um that I think we have a lot of reasons
not to speed up because basically
um Independence can be increased by a
speeding up of the expansion of
Renewables
um the plan is to be four times as fast
in the future as we have been in the
past so if we reach that
um we are
um at the end of this decade in a
position where we really are less
dependent on energy Imports and I hope
we get there quite soon in the meantime
so uh the ramp up can of course be not
from today to tomorrow so in the
meantime we have to improvise
um and we have also to focus on not only
the renewable energy plants but also on
the networks on the network for
electricity in order to distribute the
electricity
um all about all around Europe and also
on the networks for the distribution of
hydrogen because we have to import
um first of course LNG but then later on
hydrogen and renewable energy carriers
which are climate neutral or more
climate friendly and then of course if
we import them we have to have the
infrastructures to distribute them and
these are all
um things that we have to initiate right
now and I think
um the Russian aggression against
Ukraine gives us a reason to really
speed up to really get this done in
order to become independent and more
um depend more um based on renewable
energies in Germany and of all over
Europe of course
well there's been a criticism for
Germany's Reliance on gas coal and
nuclear and of course you're talking
about let's see what we can do to move
away from those as quickly as possible I
understand that but at the moment it
seemed almost like a a pipe dream that
one day we'll be able to reliably store
um renewable energy that comes in from
solar and from wind but we're not there
yet we don't have batteries that are
practical and big enough to be able to
switch them on whenever we need them
whenever there is a sudden spike in an
energy need that we could just turn to
them
um so is this all just a pipe dream or
are we going to actually be able to make
practical steps without just relying on
a bridge fuel like gas for decades and
decades to come
no that's actually no dream I think
um I think there are many ways I think
we will need for the energy transition
towards Renewables a lot of different
Technologies
um we didn't need the Renewables in
Germany and in Europe we will have to
um be to produce more and and to install
more renewable capacities in Europe
build the networks in order to
distribute this energy and we have some
possibilities to store energy as well so
there is water power in the mountains
um there is as a possibility to produce
hydrogen from your renewable electricity
and store it and um use it for a power
um production when the Renewables don't
deliver
um and there is of course
um also the possibility to install
batteries in order to have a short run
flexible abilities so we will have a
mixture of batteries for the short run
flexibility in the system and hydrogen
as a possibility to store electricity
over long periods of times for example
from Summer to Winter in order to have
more energy at our disposal in the
winter so I think this is very
um realistic we can get that
technologically this is possible we need
to induce the incentives regulatory
framework that makes the things going
and that gives the firms the right
incentives to build up these renewable
climate neutral Energy Systems
okay and um just before we look ahead to
2023
um I want us to hear from Germany's
Energy Minnesota War but hardbeck his
assessment let's just say is is cautious
we're far from out of the woods the gas
supply in Germany is assured for this
winter provided that Germans saving
efforts and Endeavors hold up
okay so Veronica um like I said a
cautious assessment uh going ahead from
Corbett Harback there
um considering all of these moves we
just discussed
um let's get down to brass tacks how
close is Europe to reducing its
dependency on Russian gas to as close to
zero as possible are we still a long
long way off or is next year of the year
I think uh first and foremost we have to
see that we are not through after this
winter but the next winter will be much
harder
um so up to uh this year uh we had the
Russian gas in order to fill up the
storages next year at least in Germany
we will not have Russian gas in order to
fill up the storages but nevertheless we
have to get them filled until the next
winter I think the LNG Terminals and the
gas deliveries will help but we have
really to be aware that the situation is
far uh from being relaxed next year but
it is maybe even more critical than this
year and we also have to be aware
um that um the war in Ukraine will get
into a critical phase next year
um
so
um there is a necessity to get through
all this and I think it's very important
that we continue you to safeguards that
we do not interpret signals like if
there's a period
um of very good weather where it's warm
and the storages are not um uh are are
not used that much that we don't
um
do don't lose our motivation but I think
it's very important to tell the people
that the motivation has to continue uh
actually until maybe the spring of 24 I
think then we have the chance to be a
little bit through this very dense
energy situation
okay so we're in there for the the Long
Haul but um doesn't it all sound very
expensive though these big transitions
that we're having to make
um these uh New pieces of infrastructure
that we're having to build amid this
cost of living crisis and inflation
which of course is caused by the energy
problems um to to a massive extent
themselves
um can we afford it in these times to do
all that we need to do how how are
governments going to balance the books
in this case
yeah I think we have to afford it uh I
mean we have seen
um
by the Russian aggression
um on Ukraine that we are in a very
critical situation and the energy
dependencies
um that we are struggling with at the
moment are not the only dependencies we
have to see that this is only the
beginning of
um getting less dependent
um making our value chains less
dependent This concerns
um our trade relations
um there we are very dependent on China
This concerns the dependencies with
respect to critical raw materials
without critical raw materials like rare
earth or other um raw materials we will
not succeed in our energy transition so
I think we really have to see that we
have to get through this
um and the most important issue is that
we get through this that we um come out
of this uh strong and be that we can
support
Ukraine uh in their um war against
Russia
um because the worst case would be if
Ukraine would not succeed
um and this would be a much more
um this would be much more damaging for
Europe and much more costly for Europe
in terms of
um Peace in terms of lives and in terms
of of course also economic variables and
I think we have to see that we have to
get through this and we have to become
independent in the world that
um now is um forming a world where um
more might
um is um is important than rules among
the some states it is very important to
get a setup that is strong independent
and where we control our economic
relations not only in economic terms but
also in security terms
okay one last question for you let's end
on a high note what are you optimistic
about for
um Germany the European economy in 2023
I'm quite optimistic that we have the
economics
we have to
to work at is to get the right mindset
because the world really has changed in
the year of 2022 and I think we have to
realize this and I think it is a wrong
and not realistic to expect that it goes
on like this after uh this uh crisis but
the world has really changed and we have
to set up our economies in a different
way in order to sustain in the world
that is now
that is now real but I'm I'm pretty sure
that we can do this
um so the German population has um shown
to be strong in this crisis I reacted uh
quite intensively uh safe energy
um supported uh Ukraine and I think we
get through this and I'm pretty
optimistic
um that Europe will grow uh you due to
this crisis
that's that's great that's a fantastic
positive way uh to to end and thank you
Veronica Grimm for breaking all of that
down for us it's always a pleasure to
hear from you on this uh fantastic
insight and thank you for watching and
while you're here why not check out some
other great videos some business videos
of course from DW news here on our
YouTube channel thanks for watching